So to answer my question
>> the universe cannot you can have an
infinite regress of dependent things. So
it has to rely on something that's
independent. So
dear brothers and sisters as we watch
what is unfolding today in we have to
understand that opposition is counting
on us to lose attention to become
fatigued and to move on with the new
cycle. And just as we can't allow them
to dictate our attention, we also can't
allow them to dictate the pace of our
solidarity. And part of that solidarity
is going to be there to rebuild Gaza
short-term, long-term. I am proud to
give my support, my word of support to
trusted brothers and sisters in the
United Kingdom that have started a walk,
that have started an endowment to make
sure inshallah that we're there for the
long run. It's going to be long term and
we will not forget our cause in
Palestine. We will not forget the cause
of and we will not forget our brothers
and sisters in
>> from nothing. Nothing comes.
>> You cannot have us. You cannot have
matter, time, space, energy from
nothing. You can't have these things
popping out of nothing.
>> Well, maybe we can.
>> Okay. So, but but then then you can also
ask like can the creative pop out of
nothing?
>> Okay. So, so just on that point, the
onus of proof that something can come
from nothing is not on me, it's on you
because we've never experienced anything
like that in our lives. So, the onus is
on you, not on me, to prove that that's
true. Can you prove it?
Can No. Okay. You you you you're way
more used to talking this than I am. So,
so I'm going to have to think for a
moment. Like, what's the definition of
nothing?
>> I I I can't give you a good concise
definition.
>> That's a good definition. It's the
absence of something.
>> You could say that. I mean,
>> not me. Not me. Good.
>> That that's a good definition. I'm I'm
sure there's a better one in the Oxford
English station.
>> No, no, not for me. It's if you check
anyway, it's nothing is the absence of
something.
>> Yes.
>> But but we we just fundamentally don't
know how the universe was created. And
and maybe it occurred from nothing.
Maybe it occurred from a creator. May
maybe it came from something else. We
just fundamentally don't know because
there was nobody there was nobody there
to see it.
>> If I was to ask you a question, you're
talking about underdetermination right
now, right? There's many different
possibilities.
>> You previously said evolution is the
explanation for why we're here.
>> Yes.
We chose evolution amongst a group of
other options.
Why don't we look at the universe and
look at the different options and then
decide which one's more rational
>> rather than saying there's too many
options. Would you agree with that?
>> I mean I just um let me let me give you
three categories.
>> Okay. No I
>> I I guess maybe you're right. I don't
know. I just don't think that question
is very interesting. Okay.
>> I think the question of why the universe
is here, how it was, how it occurred or
was created in the first place because
these people are right.
>> I I just don't find it interesting.
There's so many interesting things
happening in the world between people,
whatever. It's like I don't I don't
really care. What if I was to ask you
something that you said in earlier on in
the conversation? You said it wouldn't
make a difference to you if God existed
or not. You said something like this.
Yes.
>> Yeah. Okay. What if I was to say I
disagree with that because if God exists
then we have a purpose which is
objective. If God doesn't exist, this
life is meaningless. So it does have an
existential impact on our lives. But but
but that statement may be true but that
just makes the existence of a god more
desirable. It doesn't make it more
probable.
>> Okay. Good. Good. Very good. I really
like you said that.
>> The reason why I said this is because
now the question of God is important.
I'm not saying God exists because God is
desirable. I'm saying it makes the
question of God important.
>> Wait, wait, wait. You said there was a
God made sure there's a purpose.
>> What is that purpose?
>> Okay. The purpose of life according to
Islam is to have a relationship with
God.
>> And that relationship with God is what's
going to give us happiness. I'll ask you
a simple question I ask everyone that
comes here. If I gave you a billion
dollars and you had one year to spend
it, what would you do with those billion
dollars?
I I have to spend it all in one year.
[Music]
>> I don't I might go skiing. I don't know.
>> I I I
>> You know, I'm the type of person that
will go and find a king and get a bunch
of mutants. I'm joking. Anyway, you like
do scientific experiments, buy yachts,
get cars, do other stuff. I mean, I I
like a a billion dollars on like if I
was allowed to invest it, then I could
like make sure I live like very
comfortably the rest of my life.
>> Fine.
>> But but you you asked me to spend it in
one year and I'm like it's just the
limit to how much I can
>> Okay, fine.
>> spend in one year.
>> You can spend it. Maybe I'll donate most
of it. I don't know.
>> But say you had not one year, you had
100 years. You could spend it for the
rest of your life.
>> You do everything that you found
desirable in your life. Yes. Would you
say that you have now maximum happiness?
There's no more happiness beyond these
material things.
>> No. No. I I I wouldn't. I I think
>> I think I would probably take a few
steps up. What do you call like the
hedonic treadmill and I would get used
to a higher standard of living and and I
would just set higher goals for myself
of what to achieve. Uh because now I
should be able to achieve more because I
I have like what did you say? A billion
pounds. Sure.
>> Uh, and then and then I probably
wouldn't achieve those things and maybe
I would be less happy.
>> Are you familiar with Maslo's hierarchy
of needs? Okay. What was right at the
top?
>> Self- realization, right?
>> That was the original. That was the
original sketch. What was right? What
was right at the bottom? Right at the
bottom.
>> It was like food, shelter, sleep, things
like that. As you go up the ladder,
your physical needs are being left for
something more transcendent. Yes. Okay.
The ultimate transcendent being is God.
And true happiness, the Quran says, is
when you have a relationship without
God. And this is, you know, you said
it's not desirable or it doesn't impact
your life. On the minimum, I hope today
you've seen from my perspective that God
has a meaningful impact in our lives. So
that's why the question of God is
important. It's not just an abstract uh
discussion just a nice fancy way of you
know passing time and doing philosophy.
It has a real world impact on people's
lives. This is why people turn towards
God and we can prove God exists. I'm
sorry. We can prove God exists. How how
would you prove God exists?
>> Me personally I would use the argument
from contingency. So I would say there
are three types of possibilities or
three types of exist existence. We have
impossible existence. We have uh
possible existence and we have necessary
existence.
>> Yeah. And I'll define them for you.
Yeah. The first one is an impossible
existence like a triangle square. Yeah.
We cannot have a triangle square. Would
you agree?
>> Yes. By definition, yes.
>> Yeah. Good. So we have we're left with
two existence. Number one is possible
existence which is contingent something
that relies on something else for
existence. And number two is a necessary
existence that is independent of any
need. So would you agree that me and you
are dependent?
>> Yes. Okay. So we are contingent on other
things for our survival. Yes, of course.
Good. So, eating, food, shelter, etc.
>> All those things. Yes.
>> Yeah. Good. So, would you agree that
planet Earth is dependent on other
factors for for it survival?
>> Yes.
>> Good. Would you accept that our solar
system is dependent on other things?
>> I I don't think I know enough about like
astrophysics to answer that question.
>> No, it's not a matter of knowing about
astrophysics. It's knowing that for
example in our universe, we are a planet
within our galaxy. Yes. So, we depend on
what other factors to survive. I mean
like you you have planets that that that
are wandering and don't don't uh don't
have a son, right? So I don't I don't
know. But they are they dependent? Do
they are they depend on something else
for survival?
>> I I don't know. I I I don't know the
answers to these questions. I just don't
>> No. No. But would you agree that they
are dependent?
>> I I I don't like
>> Okay. So what you want me to answer? I
just know what I'm going to answer. To
me my definition is this for something
that is contingent. It depends on
something else for exist existence. It
can be any other way and it's composed
of pieces. Would you agree that other
planets are composed of pieces?
>> Sure.
>> Okay. Then I say that is dependent.
Anything that is composed of pieces is
dependent.
>> Okay.
>> Okay. Good. So what I would say is for
example, do you uh accept that for
example our universe is it dependent or
independent?
>> I I would guess the universe is
independent.
>> Good. So that that's good for me cuz you
know why? Cuz you accept that we require
an independent thing. All you do is you
ascribe that to the universe. Now is the
universe composed of pieces?
>> Yes. Good. Can it be any other way?
>> The universe.
>> Yeah. Can you have more galaxies, less
galaxies?
>> Sure.
>> Good. So, number three, that shows me
that it is dependent because it's
composed of pieces. It can be any other
way.
>> You're you're making up all these
definitions and saying all these words
like it doesn't like we just agree the
universe was independent.
>> Like the univer the universe might just
be its own thing and there might be no
other things.
>> No, you know that.
>> No, you said it's independent which to
me remember we said there are two types
of existence. Impossible existence.
possible existence and necessary
existence. All you've done is you've
accepted that there are possible
existence and there's a necessary
existence. You ascribe the necessary
existence to the universe. My argument
is the following. If I can prove the
universe is not independent dependent.
The question I would ask you is what
does it depend on?
>> You you said it dependent on the pieces
it's made of that makes it dependent on
itself.
>> No, that's the whole point that if it's
composed of pieces and it can be any
other way, it is dependent. It's not
independent.
>> Dependent on what? those pieces like for
example you know they say the the part
comes before the heart
>> that's like saying I'm dependent on
myself and therefore I'm not dependent
>> no I never said that you're dependent if
you depend on if you depend on your
heart you're dependent
>> you don't my heart is part of me
>> good you depend on it
>> yes
>> good so you're you're dependent
>> like that that that's just circular
logic
>> that's circular logic you you depend on
your heart to be for you for you to
exist
>> it's just circular logic and that does
not in any way prove the existence of a
god I didn't even go to god dear I you
you you're you're to me it seems like
you know where it's going. You're I'm
saying to you very simply, do you depend
on water to survive?
>> Yes.
>> Yeah. You're you're dependent being.
You're a dependent being. That's fine.
So I'm saying to you the universe within
itself is is also dependent. It's not
independent.
>> We don't know.
>> It's not cuz the universe is not
self-sufficient. Let me you do know
that. For example, we require that the
universe
>> we we the universe might very well be
self-sufficient.
>> How? Prove it to me. How? I as I said
before I'm not an astrophysicist.
>> You don't need to be astrophysicist. I
can tell you that.
>> I know I Yes. I actually need to be an
astrophysicist to answer these question.
>> I'm not an astrophysicist. I know for
example,
>> you also can't answer these.
>> No, I can't. Very simply, we know the
universe is composed of pieces. It can
be any other way. You can have more
galaxies, less galaxies. Therefore, not
only that, we don't have infinite in the
real world. Can you prove to me infinite
in the real world?
>> There's like an infinite num number of
real numbers.
>> No, no, that's that's potential. That's
called potential infinite. You don't
have actual infinite.
We have there's an infinite number of
integers. There's an infinite number of
real numbers.
>> No, no, no. There's potential infinite
numbers going on, but there's no
infinite. Infinite has no number.
>> I mean, now we're just having a
semantics discussion.
>> Not really. Not really. What I'm saying
to you is the following. Yeah. You
cannot have an infinite regress of
dependent things. You require an
independent, self-sufficient, necessary
being that gave rise to all the
dependent things.
>> And that was the big bang. You You're
calling something that began to exist.
>> You're calling something that exploded.
That's dependent. The fact that he
exploded is dependent.
>> So you require what? If the big the
explosion might be independent.
>> No. How can be independent? The fact
that he exploded and needed all those
>> We don't know. We We don't know how we
don't know how it works. And I'm tired
of you being these anti-science
religious fanatics. I'm so tired
of you. No, you're just upset cuz you
I'm showing you logically and rally
>> nonsense and then you say
>> No, you're upset cuz you can't
rationally bring anything to the table.
I I understand you're upset because the
thing is when we been a logical rational
argument, you start having a tantrum. I
didn't swear at you. I didn't if I'm the
religious fanatic, you sound like a
religious fanatic cuz you fell off to
bring to the table. I'm having a
rational rational discussion politely.
You're having a breakdown. So again,
>> you're just talking nonsense. You're
just talking nonsense. Makes no sense.
If it doesn't make sense, answer it.
Maybe you should go to school to learn
some science.
>> Okay, that's fine. If you know science
better, you know, you be my teacher.
That's fine. So, I'm asking a simple
question. The big bang, how did it
explode?
>> I mean, I don't know how many times I
have to repeat myself and say I'm not
mist.
[Music]
It's simple logical and rationality.
This the argument is the following.
>> It's hard difficult science that we
don't know the answers to.
>> No, no, second. I'm not knowing the
answers. That's a copout. That's saying
I don't know the answers. Okay, that's
fine. I'm saying logically and
rationally you accepted there is a a
necessary existence and a possible
existence. We said I said to him is the
universe dependent or independent? He
said it's independent. Good. That's good
for me. Which means you agree we need an
independent thing. You ascribed it to
the universe. I proved to you why the
universe cannot be independent. It's
dependent. You did not
>> then. Yes. Yes I did. Yes I did. That's
the reason why look you depend on your
foul language because you have nothing
to bring to the table. So therefore if
the universe is dependent what does it
depend on? You just you've been
repeating yourself for 10 minutes and I
got tired because you're just repeating
something. You're tired. I'm tired.
>> Nonsense.
>> So just answer my question.
>> The universe cannot you can have an
infinite regress of dependent things. So
it has to rely on something that's
independent. I thought so. Bye Magnus.
It's been a pleasure. As you can see,
you know, you know, look, I admire I
admire
patience. Okay. I was listening. Yeah.
And I was like uh yeah I I have to
admise admire Sabul's way of dawa but
this guy just in waffles me you know
what I did I just shut my mouth I
thought look le did a fantastic job but
you know the moment you just put them to
a corner ask rational logical questions
in he was trying to dodge it etc no
problem was making fantastic points and
he's like oh I hear this oh I hear that
okay no problem
>> I'll tell you something funny that you
did that was really funny yeah
>> when he was cornered with me he simply
said it doesn't matter to Exactly. So
then I went into why God matters with
you. You said no no no I'll prove it to
you and and you you you did a good one
cuz it showed that you need me
hierarchy. You need the top the top is
what?
>> The top self transcendence
transcendency.
>> So he understood that the moment I'm
asking I didn't insult him. I didn't
swear at him. I just made the Russian
argument. No. You know why? Because you
can sense these kind of guys it's the
ego they worship. You know the Quran.
Have you seen the one that takes his own
desires as God? I didn't insult you. I
didn't swear.
>> I'll tell you why it happened. Yeah,
>> he knew he was filming and I said, "Are
you okay with that?" He said, "Yes." He
wanted you to be on camera
>> and then he realized bad.
>> Exactly.
>> I showed him the channel as well.
>> Magnus played Russian relate with a
Magnum and uh it didn't end well and
they literally lost.
>> He he got he got you. Look, I'm not here
to have one over the other. It's not
about that. It's it's about honesty.
>> No, but Ali, I would tell you one thing
though.
>> I was trying to be as polite as
possible.
>> He was. Yes. However, there was a lot of
arrogance.